es folgt die Neujahrsansprache des
Bundeskanzlers liebe Mitbürgerinnen und
liebe Mitbürger wenn ich im Land
unterwegs bin sagen mir gerade auch
viele ältere so geballt so Schlag auf
Schlag habe ich das alles noch niemals
erlebt kaum war Corona halbwegs vorbei
brach Russland mitten in Europa ein
unerbittlichen Krieg vom Zaun kurz
darauf dreht uns der russische Präsident
den gassarn ab und im Herbst gab es auch
noch den brutalen Terrorangriff der
Hamas auf
Israel so viel Leid so viel Blut
vergießen unsere Welt ist unruhiger und
rauer geworden sie verändert sich in
geradezu Atem beraubender
Geschwindigkeit auch wir müssen uns
deshalb verändern vielen von uns
bereitet das sorgen bei einigen sorgt
das auch für Unzufriedenheit ich nehm
mir das zu Herzen und zugleich weiß ich
wir in Deutschland kommen dadurch
erinnern Sie sich wo wir vor einem Jahr
standen 3 4 5% Wirtschaftseinbruch
hatten uns viele Expertinnen und
Experten vorausgesagt viele befürchteten
die Preise würden immer weiter steigen
es gab die Sorge vor Stromausfällen und
kalten Wohnung es ist anders gekommen
die Inflation ist gesunken Löhne und
Renten steigen die gastspeicher sind für
diesen Winter
randvoll es ist anders gekommen weil wir
uns gegen den Wirtschaftseinbruch
gestemmt haben weil wir Energie gespart
und rechtzeitig vorgesorgt haben wir
alle gemeinsam wir kommen auch mit
Gegenwind
zurecht das macht die Herausforderung
unserer Zeit nicht kleiner aber das gibt
Mut dass wir ihnen gewachsen sind wer
wenn nicht ihr in Deutschland kriegt das
hin das sagen mir viele um uns herum in
Europa und auf der Welt und da ist etwas
dran noch nie hatten so viele Frauen und
Männer in Deutschland eine Arbeitsstelle
wie heute das sichert unseren Wohlstand
das gibt uns die Möglichkeit kraftvoll
in die Zukunft zu investieren und das
müssen wir auch denn wer in diesen Tagen
mit der Bahn unterwegs ist oder vor
einer maroden Brücke im Stau steht der
merkt unser Land wurde zu lange auf
Verschleiß gefahren deshalb investieren
wir jetzt in ordentliche Straßen und
eine bessere Bahn in eine saubere
Energieversorgung und in besseren
Klimaschutz in gute Arbeitsplätze und
zwar in Wirtschaftszweigen in den
Deutschland schon immer Weltspitze war
genauso wie in Branchen wo wir
Nachholbedarf haben z.B bei der
Herstellung von Computerchips oder
Batterien all das ist voh dem
Hintergrund des weitreichenden Urteils
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts von Mitte
November nicht einfacher geworden nicht
alle Vorhaben die wir in den Blick
genommen hatten werden wir umsetzen
können aber war es zugleich wir
investieren auch im kommenden Jahr eine
Rekordsumme in unsere Zukunft und unterm
Strich entlasten wir auch weiterhin all
diejenigen die jeden Tag aufstehen und
zur Arbeit gehen die unser Land am
Laufen halten von morgen an Zahlen
Arbeitnehmern und Arbeitnehmer in
Deutschland 15 Milliarden Euro weniger
an Steuern eine vierköpfige Familie mit
einem normalen Einkommen hat dadurch im
nächsten Jahr mehr als 500 € zusätzlich
zur Verfügung zusammen mit der
Steuersenkung in diesem Jahr macht das
über 1600 € mehr dazu kommen das höhere
Kindergeld das Wohngeld und nicht
zuletzt die Senkung der Beiträge zur
Sozialversicherung für all diejenigen
die wenig verdienen die Pakete ausfahren
oder Supermarktregale einräumen die
vorherige Kinder zur Schule bringen und
noch nach der Arbeit den Haushalt
schmeißen
über sie liest man nicht jeden Tag in
der Zeitung aber mir ist es wichtig dass
Ihre Leistung gesehen und anerkannt
wird Liebe Mitbürgerin und Mitbürger
auch in Zeiten wie diesen gibt es Dinge
auf die wir uns verlassen können die uns
stark machen wir haben Freunde in Europa
und rund um den Globus Partner mit denen
ich mich Tag für Tag darüber abstimme
wie wir unsere Sicherheit in Deutschland
und Europa
gewährleisten stark macht uns die
Europäische Union wenn die EU
geschlossen auftritt dann handelt sie
für mehr als 400 Millionen Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in einer Welt mit a künftig
sogar 10 Milliarden Menschen ist das ein
echt des Pfund darum ist es so wichtig
dass Europa geeint und gestärkt aus der
Europawahl im kommenden Jahr
hervorgeht denn Russlands Krieg im Osten
unseres Kontinents ist ja nicht vorbei
die kriegerische Auseinandersetzung im
Nahen Osten auch nicht und in USA stehen
im kommenden Jahr Präsidentschaftswahlen
an möglicherweise mit weitreichenden
Konsequenzen auch für uns hier in
Europa kurz vor Weihnachten haben wir
uns in der Europäischen Union nach 7
Jahren des Stillstands auf eine
tiefgreifende Reform des europäischen
Asylsystems
geeinigt künftig können wir die
Außengrenzen Europas besser
kontrollieren und auch an den Grenzen zu
unseren Nachbarländern hat die
Bundespolizei ihre Kontrollen verstärkt
das wirkt schon in den vergangenen
Wochen ist die Zahl derer die über diese
Grenzen kommen spürbar
gesunken stark macht uns auch unsere
Demokratie es ist noch gar nicht allzu
lange her da haben mutige Frauen und
Männer auch hier in Deutschland für
freie Wahlen gekämpft vor 35 Jahren war
das als in der DDR die friedliche
Revolution
begann mitzureden und mitzuentscheiden
das ist ein kostbares Gut Diskussionen
über den richtigen Weg gehören dazu das
Ringen um faire Kompromisse
ebenfalls auch wenn ich auf manche laute
Debatte in den vergangenen Wochen und
Monaten durchaus hätte verzichten können
zur Wahrheit gehört aber auch ganz ohne
Diskussion über den richtigen Weg
funktioniert Demokratie nicht nicht wird
besser wenn wir nur übereinander reden
anstatt
miteinander stark macht uns unsere
Bereitschaft zum Kompromiss und unser
Einsatz fürüinander so wie in den Teilen
Deutschlands die in diesen Tagen unter
dem schrecklichen Hochwasser und seinen
Folgen leiden ich denke an alle
Betroffenen denen wir selbstverständlich
helfen und die wir in diesen schweren
Stunden nicht alleine lassen und ich
danke all denen Frauen und Männern von
der Feuerwehr und Bundeswehr vom THW den
Rettungsdiensten und den vielen
freiwilligen Helferinen und Helfern die
mit ganzer Kraft gegen das Hochwasser
kämpfen herzlichen Dank an sie alle für
ihren
Einsatz Liebe mitbürgerinen und
Mitbürger uns macht auch die Einsicht
stark dass jede und jeder gebraucht wird
in unserem Land die spitzenforscherin
genauso wie der Altenpfleger die
polizisen genauso wie der Paketbote die
Rentnerin genauso wie wie der Junge
auszubilden wenn wir uns das klar machen
wenn wir uns gegenseitig mit diesem
Respekt begegnen dann brauchen wir keine
Angst zu haben vor der Zukunft dann kann
das Jahr 2024 ein gutes Jahr werden für
unser Land auch wenn manches anders
kommt als wir uns das heute am Vorabend
dieses neuen Jahres vorstellen Ihnen und
Ihren Liebsten wünsche ich von ganzem
Herzen ein gesundes ein friedvolles und
ein frohes neues
Jahr